[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
landsleute
morgen jährt sich der tag des mauerfalls
es ist ein ganz besonderes historisches
ereignis in der jüngeren geschichte
unseres landes wie kein anderes bauwerk
symbolisierte dieses gebilde die
entzweiung des deutschen volkes und die
fremdherrschaft durch zwei weltmächte
die unser land im herzen europas für
ihren kalten krieg ein spannenden die
einen nannten es den antifaschistischen
schutzwall für die anderen war es die
kommunistische land mauer
ich nenne es heute den antideutschen
trennwand oder den limes bis zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in der nacht auf den 9
november 1989 bezwang die bürger der ddr
diesen trend war mitsamt der
dazugehörigen drohkulisse bestehend aus
grenzsoldaten stacheldraht minen und
selbstschussanlagen am 9 november 1989
wurde der bann dieses symbols gebrochen
in vielen deutschen familien flossen in
dieser nacht die freudentränen
nun konnte wieder zusammenwachsen was
zusammengehört
für viele von uns ging ein traum in
erfüllung den selbst deutsche politiker
nicht mehr zu träumen wagen
für uns ein traum für andere ein
alptraum
herr maas sie liege völlig daneben mit
ihrer aussage die deutsche einheit sei
auf wunsch der europäer zustande
gekommen das haben sie in ihren worten
in der prager botschaft die ich selbst
gehört habe erzählt es wäre schön wenn
es tatsächlich so gewesen wäre
aber die realität sah anders aus ich
habe die aussagen von maggie thatcher
und anderen namhaften europäischen und
deutschen politikern vor allem aus der
spd noch im ohr und schmerzen mich noch
heute
die tun uns keinen gefallen der mars
wenn sie hier die tatsache verschleiern
die umwälzung
der deutschen einheit bescherten die
neuen bundesländern neue freiheiten und
möglichkeiten
aber sie bisher hatten uns auch einen
beispiellosen raubzug durch die treuhand
er noch längst nicht aufgearbeitet ist
und dessen vor allem die menschen in
mitteldeutschland heute immer noch
spüren die einheit beschert uns auch
neue politiker zum beispiel die
amtierende kanzlerin angela merkel
ich bedauere dass sie uns nicht verrät
welche herrschafts und zersetzung
strategien sie damals bei der fdj
gelernt hat wie man ein volk mit
agitationen
wie man ein volk mit agitation und
propaganda in schach hält das ist ja
wertvolles wissen dass uns dabei helfen
könnte den riss zu kippen der heute
wieder durch deutschland geht
wie haben sie das eigentlich geschafft
vermerkt dass heute wieder ein
antifaschistischer bzw
ein anti deutscher trennen weil unser
land verteilt diese entwicklung fällt in
ihrer amtszeit und dafür sind sie auch
verantwortlich oder glauben sie etwa
dass ihre untertanen ihre vielen mikro
aggressionen die alles deutsche
entgangen sind
ich kann auch kaum glauben dass eine
frau so wenig mitgefühl und liebe zu dem
volk empfindet dass sie selbst regiert
und repräsentiert ihre
beileidsbekundungen ihre
beileidsbekundungen an die angehörigen
der opfer vom breitscheidplatz erfolg
der ein jahr später als der kleine junge
in frankfurt mutwillig vor dem zug
gestoßen wurde
tragen sie schweigend ihren urlaub an in
einem boot regierten land hätte das
staatsoberhaupt trauerbeflaggung
angeordnet aber erfolgte nichts
sollte ich ihnen mal sagen wann menschen
gut und gerne in einem land leben wenn
sie das gefühl haben dass ihr lang von
personen regiert wird die auch um ihr
emotionales wohlergehen bemüht sind
die bürgerrechtlerin bärbel bohley hat
vor 29 jahren davor gewarnt dass die
stasi methoden die ddr überleben würden
die sagt er und ich zitiere man wird
diese strukturen genauestens untersuchen
um sie dann zu übernehmen
man wird sie ein wenig adaptieren damit
sie zu einer freien westlichen
gesellschaft passen man wirklich gehöre
auch nicht unbedingt verhaften
es gibt feinere möglichkeiten jemand
unschädlich zu machen
aber die geheimen verbote das beobachten
der argwohn
die angst das isolieren und ausgrenzen
das brandmarken und mundtot machen derer
die sich nicht anpassen das wird wieder
kommen meint einrichtung schaffen
die viel effektiver arbeiten viel feiern
heißt die stasi auch das ständige lügen
wird wieder kommen die desinformation
der nebel in dem alles seine kontur
verliert zitat ende
[Applaus]
und weil ich gerne mit einer
hoffnungsvollen botschaften tag des
mauerfalls enden würde schließlich mit
einem und strom in meinem traum
existiert wieder ein gutes deutsches
volk im herzen europas
das zu seinen guten traditionen und
werten steht ein deutsches volk ein
deutsches volk gegen den frieden in der
welt und europa am herzen liegt und dass
sich dabei trotzdem nicht selbst
verleugnet ein land das gelernt hat das
ist ruhig aber bestimmt nein sagen darf
und sich auch nicht ausbeuten und zu
spüren was muss ein land mit gesunden
grenzen indem man sich auch als
deutscher geborgen und wertgeschätzt
fühlt mit grenzen die uns schützen
anstatt uns zu entzweien
vielen dank zwei länder ein volk hat
willi